cédric doleyres lui gilet jaune libre
vous étiez à matignon la semaine
dernière c'est bien mais c'est très bien
passé mais qu'est ce qui s'est dit
abattu nous respecte d'ailleurs aux
trois esquisser des pas une conversation
très sérieuse on a fait le point de de
la détresse la coque français on a fait
le point
on a surtout parlé aussi de du sera bol
du racket fiscal
depuis trente ans on a échangé avec le
premier ministre
on a porté les revendications pas les
vôtres
les revendications des gilet jaune alors
il est vraiment arribes renard l'été sûr
comme je suis berné les faits
reviendrait l'essentiel peut mordre à
tour les clients et jay garner porter
les revendications des jeunes et jolies
dg les jaunes libre aussi puisque ce
sont les mêmes
alors mamadou a distingué ont alors
commencé les italiens justement d'un
joli un pléonasme baisse conjuguée des
jaunes et libre dans des créations donc
bon on peut jay dodge et jaune il est
double ils sont tous les français qui
sont gilet jaune ne sont pas forcément
gilet jaune la même façon que tu es
gilet jaune n'aura fusion commence à se
disent à se différencier entre 2 et 5 cm
non c'est pas de la session s'est
balancé mais nous aurons givré comme tu
ne le cnca de fruits sains
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est vrai que c'est eric oui toi
tu es contre la manifestation
je pense que demain tu as tu appelles
and trade je préfère une trêve riz comme
il s'est dit étonné par son pouvoir
pourquoi pas tout simplement on a le
premier ministre par rapport à ce qu'on
lui a apporté tu voulais pas faire ça à
laëtitia mais rapport à ce qu'ont
apporté ces faits le messager auprès du
président il a apporté des avancées
alors soit effectivement sefa pas
forcément suffisant bien d'accord avec
ça mais j'avais toujours les avancées
c'est vrai que toi bah ouais y'a quoi un
petit peu de jeu de bonneteau parce que
sur les 100 euros
oui il ya absents euros de plus mais il
ya quand même un petit peu d'artifices
tout ça c'est que cédric est ce que vous
êtes au courant
samassa même tombé sur l'orientation
aura peut-être pas lieu au 1er janvier
mais mois de juin parce que les cavs
sont pas du tout prête à laisser cette
activité vous êtes c'est la même alerte
d'un article sorte il est alors c'est
vrai ronnie wood informé le président
daouda il faut que vous acceptez de
croire qu entreprise la plus cool
gouvernement vous parle donc c'est un
nom sur le croire sur parole le
président de région il faut quoi joue
pas contre le progrès sur parole je suis
désolé savez vous savez comment ça se
joue sur les textes de loi que je vois
rien à aucun instant et on n'est pas
juste de dire ce qui se passe oui il ya
des gilet jaune qui étaient ici l'a
soigné depuis les gens de partout dans
la rue qui ont demandé qu'on parle et
des jeunes qui demandent qu'on dialogue
pas qu'on donne des cacahuètes patron
donne des matches aura bien lieu mais
janvier au mois de juin la hausse à lait
pour le mois de janvier c'est sûr sondés
placent jurait d'urgence elles sont
prêtes à verser cette somme est et s'il
vous plaît c'était on propose deux
choses aux deux questions principales
des gilets jaunes des mesures d'urgence
pour le pouvoir d'achat pour finir les
blâmer fins de mois et hors d'eux une
vraie négociation mais négociations
ruines vous allez garder vos jambes et
on est d'accord que le smic n'augmente
pas 200 euros sert que pour les
retraites ça ne marche pas comme ça il
augmente de
villarreal à vous dire à la retraite
c'est pas la même chose
monsieur lavaud stressant juste alexis
dante au le smig dans les salles pour
tenir le petit tueur au taxi parce que
oui je suis revenu sur un truc mais
monsieur monsieur vous dire monsieur
cahuzac
est ce que oui ou non ce sera un genre
sont paralysés fait madame ça me
gênerait mais après ça reste d'accord
monsieur money aussi réjoui est ce que
oui ou non ce sera en janvier il a 10 e
ce sera ma soeur maintenant si vous le
dites donc c'est sûr non mais il se sera
janvier donc cette langue à cheverny
donc l'article c'est du pipeau c'est du
pipeau s'il vous plaît ça rit ça va oui
j'en ai des buy in sera janvier une
chute news je sais bien s'allier et des
articles à 90% du pipeau s'il vous plaît
ce que tous les fonctionnaires nous tous
les samedis à l'elysée vous êtes une
militante en février porté votre voyage
vous écoute moi j'étais nourri tant que
toi viens ici moi je faisais foule c'est
là vous de ce soir et je vous écoute
regarde et je suis là et donc madame
s'il vous plaît je comprends mais vous
l'avez déjà dit à plusieurs reprises je
vous ai fait des propositions sur la
question
camille calais va tous les
fonctionnaires pour tous les
fonctionnaires d'ailleurs oui mais en
plus il faut rappeler dire il ya eu du
point d'indicé pour les fonctionnaires
les fonctionnaires ont perdu du perdu de
son élan sur leurs doigts 21 millions